was your first kiss in an audition or on
camera no it was in a movie on camera
yeah the first time you kissed a boy was
ever on a movie yes crazy I know it was
this movie I was 13 and I was trying to
keep it a secret from like the director
and and from the there's another girl
who was 17 and I was like trying to keep
a secret because I didn't want them to
know that I hadn't kissed a boy before
and in this scene I had to kiss someone
and they're like they eventually like
found out they're like okay like she's
never they could just like tell she's
nervous about it whatever so they pull
out this giant binder full of boys like
it's this big binder full of boys of
like models and actors and they're like
hell okay we're all gonna sit around and
and flip through and and you can pick
out the boy that you want to kiss for
your first time where is this binder
I just realized that came out wrong I'm
like where's this binder no I don't want
the binder that just seems crazy to me
that they're like don't worry get the
bind
flying in is so crazy so you've got to
flip through pick the boy the guy that
you like yes and then and then yeah then
we kissed on Cameron's I think she used
like that first shot or was she used
like the first time that I kissed in the
movie so it's it's captured on film I
think everybody is wanting you know so
many of us could have used our version
of that do you know what I mean like I
could have used when I was nervous about
the first time I was gonna if someone
had brought in a binder yeah we got this
all taken care of
don't worry just put a girl out of this
bind to see it's gonna be okay that
would have changed my life yeah this is
a horrifying conversation
you